that's what guys my name is the shona
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at the
beginnings of the whole I am GUI Dr
situation basically being able to have a
docking layout for our window and then
that way we can drag panels around and
we can dock them and do all that fun
stuff check out that video if you
haven't already that was last week's
episode today we're going to continue on
with that but we have kind of the new
problem that we got up to last time
which was how do we actually take our
scene and the whole kind of scene
rendering that we have going on and
actually display that as part of a
docking panel and the answer to that is
when you basically need to render it to
a texture and then we can actually use
that texture as part of I'm GUI
something that we are hopefully going to
do today so let's jump into the code and
take a look at how that's going to work
so basically today's episode is gonna be
all about frame buffers if you don't
know what frame buffers are I don't
think I actually have an OpenGL video on
that I probably make more OpenGL videos
if you guys want to see that as part of
the OpenGL series and you want it you
want more information on frame buffers
in general from me then let me know and
I might you know make an episode on that
hopefully but as it stands right now I
think that I'm missing a lot of things
in that in that series unfortunately so
that's the way it is let's fade to this
so you guys didn't really say anything I
don't know I didn't see too much about
the FaceCam so if you if you you liked
the face cam if you want to keep the
face cam and you know let me know if you
want me to remove it let me know and I
will I will do whatever you guys want
because I am such a nice person that way
you know also because I can't decide
whether I like it so let's not talk too
much let's actually do some work because
my goal as I mentioned last time last
time we took we talked a lot about what
we actually wanted to do with hazel in
general and I think that I think that a
big thing that we wanted to do was
obviously other the big thing that I
kept talking about was that I want to
get it to a state where you guys can
actually make 2d games within the hazel
with no c++ no no like maybe a little
bit of scripting into the program but no
like C++ programming or anything should
just be able to construct it using the
editor so we obviously have a lot of
work to do and I'm gonna stop talking
about that so this is what we did last
time we had this kind of image being
displayed
with I'm GUI and today what we're going
to do is when I kind of build on that
and we're going to implement frame
buffers so what we need to do is this
and it's also it obviously helps to
define what what it is you need to do
before you start working on it let me
just enable this I added this I didn't
commit anything last time during the
actual episode I did that kind of stuff
just making sure that I'm recording I
did that kind of stuff afterwards when I
actually like stopped recording and then
I was like what was kind of useless
because if I commit this and push it to
the main branch maybe I should have
branched and like made a new branch
branch branch whatever I still don't
think I've decided how I want to say it
but anyway I probably should have done
that and maybe that way it would be okay
but pushing to master you know in a
state that did not render the 2d scene
draw because we had docking enabled you
know but no actual frame buffer setup I
thought that was a bit a bit bad to do
so I quickly added that little bull in
there so because this is what this is
the actual view right this is what we
have we have this full screen hazel
engine kind of editor with this kind of
panel that is dockable as long as it's
actually part of this window because you
can also drag it outside of the window
like this if you do this you can see
it's actually a separate window over
here we have the settings window and you
can't dock this I think until it's like
you know if you grab it a certain way or
whatever it has to be in this view like
it is now and then you can like dock it
or whatever I don't know sometimes you
can like that so it's a bit weird anyway
this I'm giving stuff is fairly
experimental as far as I know so they
haven't finished it so hopefully
everything will get better so anyway
yeah so we have this we obviously have
no scene our goal is instead of
rendering this extra let's render the
scene to add extra so how do we do that
it's actually very simple frame buffers
aren't particularly difficult to deal
with in OpenGL basically like creating a
nice API for them is probably harder
than what this is and in fact I did want
to I remember maybe we'll do this next
time I did want to actually create a new
project being a kind of editor project
because this is currently in sandbox and
it shouldn't be and for that reason
that's why I had to do these these crazy
hacks but anyway docking is going to be
enabled and hopefully we will have
something on the screen today that is
from our frame buffer so the first thing
we want to do is basically look at where
we're doing all of our
during which is here and what we want to
do is instead of rendering this scene
and doing like the clear I guess as well
and doing all of that stuff just like
this we want to first bind a frame
buffer do all of our stuff and then just
end the scene and that's it and if we
have a actual texture attachment into
that frame buffer which acts as our
color buffer then obviously when our
scene gets rendered and all of that
stuff gets rasterized it's going to you
know it's gonna go into that texture and
that texture is going to be what we're
going to then display this is very very
similar to the actual like swap chain
and everything is just an open gel you
don't really control the swap chain
something like a Vulcan you explicitly
make basically frame buffers or textures
for each kind of swap chaining image you
have so in other words if you're using
like triple buffering if you've got
double buffering uh triple buffering you
would have two or three actual textures
and you have to make that as part of the
Vulcan swap chain not something that we
have to do in OpenGL has done for us and
so because of that I actually think it
makes this part maybe harder for some
people because they're like what what's
going on well all that's going on is
that again we're creating a texture
literally like any other texture there's
literally no difference in the simple
case there's no difference that's just a
regular texture and then we're saying
that hey render our scene to this
texture instead of rendering our scene
to the screen basically even though
behind the scenes technically of course
it gets rendered still onto an
off-screen buffer and then swapped onto
the screen now the only other thing to
take note of is the fact that a color
buffer texture is usually not enough we
also usually want a depth buffer texture
now technically we run during 2d stuff
only and my opinion of how to render 2d
heat is pretty much don't use the depth
buffer even though we're doing that now
this is just for simplicity sake but
usually if you're rendering 2d you
probably want to avoid that using the
death buffer and simply render
everything in reverse order that way
you'll always kind of you won't get
things like the Zed fighting for example
because you're rendering stuff in the
same axis on the same Z value because
you're not there you're not supposed to
have a Z value if it's you know you're
not supposed to have depth in a 2d scene
otherwise it's not really technically
it's 3d anyway let's uh let's actually
let's get on with it I don't know if you
guys like these kind of chats as
I don't know if I feel like I've been
like between you and me feeling a little
bit insecure about this but I just feel
like I've I don't know if you guys want
to necessarily hear though if you just
want me to get to the to actually
writing the code because obviously like
we're still going to write all the code
that we set out to write today it's just
that it might result in longer video for
you and for that I'm sorry if you're not
into that but if you are then great
because I feel like talking
sometimes all right anyway um so the
first step really is to create you know
a frame buffer class I'm not gonna write
any OpenGL card here to demonstrate how
it works because that's probably
something for the OpenGL series so once
we inside the renderer I'm going to make
a new file here called frame buffer dot
H and it will also make a frame buffer
dot CVP and then under platform OpenGL
we're going to make a class called
OpenGL a frame buffer because we're
going to have an implementation for
OpenGL now a frame buffer itself can
have a lot of different a lot of and I
think some people were complaining about
the text being too small transmit more
um a lot of other things yeah frame
buffers so frame but the the thing that
this is way too big the thing that was
the thing with frame buffers better
sneeze I came back from my sneeze break
the thing the thing about frame buffers
is that desktop there's a lot of
different there's a lot of information
that you might want to specify it's or
because the way the frame was the way
the frame of his work especially if you
spent any amount of time with them
you'll find is that the this is our
McCall this is normal in renderer the
way that they work is that rather their
use cases and the things that you want
them to be able to do is actually quite
quite comprehensive because frame
buffers can be used for a lot of
different things you might be using a
frame buffer like we are to simply
render this scene you might be using a
frame buffer as part of like a post
effects pipeline but you also might be
using a frame buffer as like a shadow
map or like some kind of like what's the
cool example I don't like maybe like
your character
we're characterizing grass and you want
the grass to be trampled and so you
might be like you know rendering
basically the characters position onto
like some mask which is like part of a
frame buffer so you can then do some
cool stuff there too like offset vertex
positions and stuff like that like you
might be you could use all of that stuff
that I've just described uses frame
buffers and so in some cases for a
shadow map for example you might want a
2048 by 2048 frame buffer and that's
that but for something like this you
want the frame buffer to be the size of
your window maybe you're trying to save
some performance like if you're
rendering on a phone or something like
that and you have like a 4k display on
like an Android device you can't render
at 4k so what you do is you render it
like 1280 by 720 or 1920 by 1080 and
then you upscale it at the end so your
scene has to get ran into a frame buffer
which has a texture that's like 1920 by
1080 or something like that which is
exactly half of the resolution of the
phone so that might be a factor of like
0.5 or something so anyway you might
have a lot of different things at play
there and so you might not necessarily
want a hard-coded particular size like
2048 by 2048 for a frame buffer you
might want it to be a percentage of the
screen and if the screen gets resized
like on a Windows computer if you go
fullscreen or if you just drag the
window and you just make the size bigger
then you will need to recreate those
frame buffers and so that is something
that I call like a kind of dynamically
resizable frame buffer and then you
might have something that isn't like
that and that is fixed like a 2048
shadowmap so my point is there are a lot
of little things to think about when it
comes to frame buffers and that's why
I'm going to introduce this new little
thing that I like to do which is
creating a struct called frame buffer
specification and then this is actually
a struct of properties this is just
something that I've started doing lately
in my code I don't really know where I
got it from I just kind of because I
came up with it I'm sure a lot of people
do this though it's very useful instead
of basically having a frame buffer
constructor that could be very
complicated and very long and might have
things like you know with hide format
you know whether or not the part of the
swap chain if it's multi sampled or not
you know there's so many different
things that you might want to you know
do you want to create a color buffer
automatically if you want to death
buffer like this might be so much stuff
to pump to put into a frame buffer
constructor that it gets overwhelming so
instead and in fact we don't even have a
constructor because technically we
should be having like a ref framebuffer
create because we actually need to
create the correct instance but the
point is what I like to do for classes
like that is create this specification
struct and this can have anything and
the cool thing is it doesn't just it
it's not just that it can have anything
it can also have values for anything so
for example I could have you know with
and I could actually set it to something
now this is a bit weird like with width
specifically as an example and let me
word base um with wit like this is it's
weird to have a default width I guess
potentially maybe the default which
should be whatever the application width
is but you know you can do stuff like
this you know with high you know we
could have for example samples and we
could set that to one by default you
know that's done that's the equivalent
of just having like a default parameter
that you set to one or something like
that here but the cool thing is we can
do that it doesn't have to be in a
certain order because we're default
parameters you have to have them at the
end obviously and they might clash with
other overloads and it's just a bit of a
disaster but with this you know we can
have it this way also probably need a
format frame buffer format maybe you
know we can set that to a default value
you guys kind of get the point like we
can I really like this approach and then
all we have to do is just pass in like a
constant reference of this into here as
a constant of specification just spec or
something right and this and that's that
and then this can get stored as part of
the frame buffer class
so inside opengl frame buffer you know
this this is extends frame buffer and
then we basically in like privately here
we just store the specification like
that and then usually what i mandate is
that we basically have to have a virtual
virtual one of these virtual frame of a
specification get specification ant's
return I'm sorry this is pure virtual
and then usually like you're and after
that depends on the class but you can
have a non-constant as well just because
sometimes it might help to actually like
sometimes you might
to change the specification it's just
that if you do then if you change it
this way then obviously nothing will be
notified of the change and if you change
the width or height of a frame buffer
you probably want to rebuild that frame
buffer so that can be a little bit
challenging I guess in this situation
you probably want something like set
specification or you'd manually have to
call on specification change or whatever
which is why we're gonna leave it Const
for now but just know that this is like
an option and for some classes it is
quite useful as long as you actually
call that code correctly and obviously
when you're designing in an API you want
to make it as much as possible you
basically want to make it impossible to
incorrectly use your API so yeah okay
anyway let's pop over to the CPP file
include our PCH include our frame buffer
class namespace hazel and and I also
want to implement this create function
and I also want to include haslett
platform and not inside hazel I'm just a
platform platform OpenGL
[Music]
and then obviously what we'll do is what
we do in every other render API class
like vertex like buffer or something we
do a little switch statement so let's
copy that and then let's just say render
a JP I and that's inside the renderer
and then we'll return obviously an Open
GL frame buffer and I'm gonna possum
that spec okay that's that so I think
that looks pretty good to me again with
the format we'll deal with that and with
specifically how we want to create color
buffers and depth buffers and stuff like
that might be something to do to deal
with as well but what I want to also do
here is I want to float some float an
idea and that is we're gonna actually
have a
and I'll call this swap chain targets
now this son sounds kind of fancy but
what this means and this is just again a
lot of this is inspired by hazel dev
because obviously I work on those of you
don't know which is probably none of you
had this right but um I work on a
version of hazel in my spare time so not
on this not in this series it's called
hazel dev it's like the development like
branch of hazel and that's got like you
know the 3d and the level editor and all
that stuff that I'm getting to see ably
explaining every time I mention he's all
that but obviously that code has a lot
of that code base is a lot larger and
more mature because I've been using this
stuff for like I don't know frame
buffers have been in there for like
probably over a year so clearly I've
added and more stuff to them I've
refined them and I've done all that
stuff so a lot of stuff is that I'm
writing here is inspired in fact I I
mean I've got hazel dev open on my other
monitor here and I'm probably going to
be like to straight-up copying some code
from the frame buffer class because I'm
not gonna pretend that I have memorized
the OpenGL API when it comes to making
frame buffers so a lot of the
inspiration comes from that and so
something that we have there is
something called swap chain target now
the reason is that at one point hazel
did work with Vulcan because I just had
a little fun weekend once where I was
just like let's jam in Vulcan so I did
that into like this 2d version of hazel
and I guess will will probably end up
doing something as similar I don't know
if we'll get around to the dis year but
I'd like to because we probably will
since we want to do max support and
eventually Linux Linux can run up in
jail fine Mac the Mac OpenGL story which
is not what his videos about so I'm not
going to take too long we're talking
about this but we basically won't want
to use metal on Mac realistically and
then so because of that we'll probably
end up doing metal before we end up
doing Vulcan but again it's not gonna
take two so I'm gonna take as long as
you guys probably think um Vulcans gonna
take a while anyway because it's
supportive welcome there was like I made
the single swatch and target this
basically says that this frame buffer is
supposed to be rendering to the Swap
chain so in other words this is the
equivalent in OpenGL as you
find out soon if you haven't already if
you don't already know it's the same as
saying chilled by an frame buffer zero
it's basically saying unbind all of my
frame buffers I want to render to the
screen so that's what this means so what
this is what this allows you to do is it
allows you to create a frame buffer that
doesn't really exist this is important a
little bit later because once we have
frame buffers we're going to be
introducing something soon ish called
render passes and a render pass is not
it's not it's it's more of an abstract
concept in OpenGL but basically the way
that I treat a render pass is a render
pass is something that has a frame
buffer has a target right so in other
words if you want to render something
you say render a begin render pass and
then that ret and then you pass in a
render pass object and that render pass
object will contain a target for that
render pass at the very minimum at the
very minimum that's what a render pass
is it's just a frame buffer and so that
frame buffer can obviously be just the
screen if you want to render directly to
the screen then you have you have a
frame buffer in that render pass that
has a swap chain target of false and
what I'm sorry so I print out of true
and what that means is that that is not
an off-screen buffer that is this screen
so please render my render pass to the
screen and that's how you eventually get
stuff onto the screen in something like
OpenGL where you know rendering to the
screen means do not have a frame buffer
at all this is getting a little bit
ahead of myself but I just wanted to
explain this video is gonna be now long
I just wanted to explain like a little
bit of my thought process behind like
why you know why why certain things are
the way they are because in the future
like I'm a little bit more aware of
what's going to happen in the future
then I guess what I may be explained
because if I explain everything like I
am right now it takes forever so anyway
let's go on let's get on with this so I
swap trade target are we rendering to
the screen or are we not all right so
let's let's jump into OpenGL frame
buffer and then obviously you know we
construct this the same way we construct
all of our classes and like render
passes is something that actually
easiest in development so in Vulcan
there's actually like an object called
like a render
path so the same way that we have like
jail frame buffer like we have frame
buffers in OpenGL Vulcan also has render
passes so in like a render pass in hazel
would translate to an actual real render
pass in Vulcan but in OpenGL if that's
your api of choice like if your
rendering using it OpenGL and hazel then
obviously it basically emulates that but
the thing is it's not like emulating it
as bad in fact I like the concept of
render passes I think they make a lot of
sense and they actually kind of help you
organize your scene all the better in my
opinion okay so in goes the cons frame
of a specification and then you know I'm
I don't really want to do a 180 on this
entire card base but the way that we've
been setting this stuff up some of the
stuff I want to change for example buy
it unbind I'm not a big fan of this it's
something that a lot of is something
that I liked in as part of the OpenGL
series I decided to include it in hazel
but using it in hazel def and stuff like
it's not bad but I don't necessarily
like this object-oriented approach all
the time so we might be making changes
to that so what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually not going to well I might have
to because we don't have a renderer yet
but basically in the future like I would
not expect frame buffer to have bind
unbind because a frame buffer should
just be an object which is essentially a
set of data that the renderer then
basically looks at and does what it
needs to with that data so in other
words like you know we're still going to
have you know you and 32 T M renderer ID
or whatever I think we look at texture
yes we're using you and 30 T's for that
cool just it could in hazel dev I have
like a I have an actual render ID type
so sometimes I just like to make sure
that I'm doing right thing um anyway
[Music]
let's press and look hard
let's create this stuff specification
okay so the idea is here we want to
actually create the frame buffer so
we'll type in create and the
specification has been set now I the way
that I like to write this is actually by
having bass appeared they could be a
public function even called resize and
resize basically just resize it
recreates it I mean you could call it
invalidate you can call it anything you
want maybe we'll call it invalidate
because resize implies that it should
take in at width and height but we're
actually reading it from the
specification so invalidate basically
just says and in hazel dev it's called
resize so again like you know not that's
really consistent but in this case I
thought maybe invalidate would be a
better word yeah so invalidate says that
the state is not valid so recreated
right so what we want to do here is
include Gilad and we're gonna write some
open GL code finally so this is going to
basically say GL create frame buffer
frame buffers we're gonna pass in that
renderer ID straight away we're going to
delete frame buffers in the destructor
because I always forget that and then
people with full requests come in so
we'll bind the frame buffer I'm I don't
need to bind it it depends how we use it
I guess let me take a look at some hazel
dev card so the next step really is to
create a color attachment I mean because
that's what a frame buffer really is
made out of so usually what I do is
create textures and then we have like a
color buffer attachment so we'll say
color attachment now the thing is this
should be completely dynamic and
customizable you shouldn't necessarily
be doing this for every frame buffer
because you might not need a frame
buffer with a color attachment well
maybe you need a frame buffer with
full-color attachments well maybe you
want to frame buffer with a depth maybe
you want it without that so there's a
lot of customizability when I
comes to this it's just that since we're
kind of you know not trying to ride a
super super cool spring on with this
size the target you're gonna be at extra
today because we're not trying to create
us like a super uber frame upper class
today I think it's fine to do that now I
am binding a texture and hazel dev coat
but I think I don't need to do that
because the idea is what I want to do
there's two ways that this goes you can
either use I think texture storage or
you can use texture image now these are
actually different and I think it's just
probably text image today I'm not
understand sure what the API is text
image though since it takes in a target
and not a type imply it like it makes me
think that it's a bit old but ultimately
the difference between an image in a
storage is that a storage as far as I'm
aware is something that you can't you
can't late a sample in a shader because
it's like it's just something that
OpenGL might need internally for example
a depth buffer is not typically
something that you sample in a shader
like and I just mean in our case
obviously in 3d graphics sampling a
depth buffer initiator is extremely
useful but for what we're doing for
example we've never had to do that yet
and so therefore if we were adding a
depth but for attachment to this we
wouldn't necessarily need it to be
available as an actual texture that we
can bind and then sample from so in that
case we could just use two extra storage
because we need the storage for it but
we don't need the access image implies
that it's something that you can
actually that you want to sample so
again there's probably a I don't know
why it's not coming up but there's my
brain maybe like I feel I thought guilt
extra image to the exists but it doesn't
but I don't know I might be completely
wrong here because there is texture
storage but there's no texture image so
maybe social storage is what you're
supposed to use but I get I'm not sure
if that's ample able whatever maybe
someone in the comments knows more than
me and would be nice enough to correct
me
so this visit are the format okay so
what we're gonna do RGBA eight so the
what that means
an RGBA you know eight bits per channel
kind of for sorry yeah 8 bits for
channel right so one byte per channel
for Matt here you know this is something
that is likely to change because they
imagine it would probably be rendering
even though it is a 2d scene rendering
in HDR is nice in which case we use GA
what is it just float32 air for 1604
what is it is still odd your base he's
gonna have I think float16 F or some
other format maybe I think you were
saying else anyway RGB i-16 f is what
you would use for or 32 F is what you
would use for like a floating-point
texture essentially something that is
not in that 0 to 1 range and can be like
high dynamic range so that you can store
color values greater than your normal
kind of range which is useful because
then you can you know map them into the
appropriate space and do what do
whatever you want with them later
because you have that extra information
but we're just gonna stick with RGB a
RGB a 8 this is something I would
probably don't even need a here but
we'll keep it um this is something that
is in the frame buffer format but we're
just gonna get this up and running today
and then we'll it will probably flush it
out maybe next time or my favorite thing
to do which is just flesh it out Adam we
need it so specification with high it's
a border of 0 format this is the data
format so this will just be geo RGB a
now unsigned byte is the type and so
we're basically making a normal texture
now you could again abstract this out
and hopefully you guys can see that
basically this is what I've written here
you can abstract this out and just you
know basically say you could just create
a texture using our texture API I'm not
a hundred percent sure if I like that
because that means that you have to
extend your texture API to be to play
nicely with the frame buffer which maybe
you want all of Europe and gel code to
make a frame buffer inside the frame
buffer class and not not abstract your
code away into a million other files
that's something that can obviously add
confusion and make everything a lot
harder so in that case you know maybe
maybe Dart
track it out but for now we'll leave
this is we'll try and have all of the
code that we need in like all the OpenGL
code we need inside this file so that
it's a little bit more clear at least
for you people at this point so texture
parameters like I want to set the
minification filter so GL was a text me
and filter so this is obviously what
happens with some Selenia this is what
happens if we're down scaling our
texture and up scaling our texture this
is the kind of way that we want to
interpolate those pixels linear is what
we want here and finally we need to
attach it so GL frame buffer texture 2d
this just attaches the texture so the
target is geo frame buffer GL color
attachment zero is what we're using here
so again you can have a lot of different
color attachments like ten well then
that was ten that came up yeah ten is
tens the maximum amount that no it's not
30 so it's 30 32 different texture
attachments is what the actual header
file supports the actual rendering
capabilities obviously up to your GPU
drivers and everything like that so text
target is going to be texture 2d and
then what else do we have here the
texture which is color attachment and
then the level which i think is the
edges zero the only thing we haven't
done is we haven't found this now I
don't know if there's a function that's
the problem with this new OpenGL stuff
there's so many different functions and
like a render buffer again is something
different something that you maybe
that's what I meant by Texas storage in
texture because I render buffer I think
it's something you can't sample from
anyway I don't know I've have too many
rendering api's in my head and I always
have to look this stuff off and
obviously this is very live and I don't
have the refugia reference in front of
me ok sir anyway
let's bind the frame buffer as well we
forgot to do that very important with
frame buffers specifically that you are
bind them because you might not
necessarily be binding them all the time
like you might not be using them all
that
time so in that sense it's very
important to make sure that you aren't
buying them because and what am i doing
geo texture 2d because if you forget -
then maybe nothing will render onto the
screen anymore because you accidentally
have some random frame buffer back okay
that's that now I will quickly also
create a depth buffer so to create a
depth buffer what do we need to do let's
see so we'll create a texture and this
will well I'm just using a texture 2d
here one and this will be our def
attachment and then we'll do binds
texture and we also need to sit boy like
multi sampling and stuff like that here
which is again something for the future
color attachment and depth attachment
and yeah these attachments will be
dynamic as I mentioned in the future so
depth - mint all this fun stuff
let's do GL text storage or jail text
image beauty so you can use gelled text
storage here target is texture 2d a
level zero internal format GL depth 24
stencil 8 so will include essential
buffer you wit as the witan high source
specification with specification high
now I'm not sure because this word now
but in hazel dev it says I'm actually
still doing a text image I've written
text image 2d gel texture 2d zero depth
stencil 8 we have a lot of stuff here
actually
I'm going to ensure what this card is
with height 0dl depth stencil unsigned
int unsigned int 24 8 which is just
referred to the first 24 bits being for
the depth buffer and then the the next 8
bits being for the stencil buffer and
then no so I don't know this is what
hazel dev has so clearly this works but
I'm gonna try text storage today because
we can't return the way that we're
making business just for urban gels use
then finally we just do frame buffer
texture 2d frame buffer and depth
stencil attachment we could have made
we've made it without the depth the
stencil buffer but in this case we'll
include it in deputation to 0 all right
this is that's it so the last thing that
you should do definitely is you should
basically just check the frame buffer
status so this just basically checks to
make sure that you know everything's
working so if the frame buffer status
right if it's equal to frame buffer
complete then the frame buffer is
completing done everything correctly so
let's wrap that into an assert and then
you know we'll say frame buffer is
incomplete so this was basically just a
little check to make sure that our frame
buffer is a plus plus all right that's
it
finally what I'll do is I will where we
out here
oh what a long episode the void binds
[Music]
void on vines so these we are gonna have
this for now just because our API kind
of needs to have them work we also need
to have these so let me just but this is
like I probably would remove these in
the future just because you shouldn't
really be taking a frame buffer object
and then calling bind on it that's very
much out of con
that's violent like that because what is
binding a frame buffer just in out out
in the open like what does that actually
mean doesn't do anything needs to be
part of a render pipeline you know it
needs to be part of like a literal
literal renderer so that's why I like to
relieve that stuff up to the renderer
anyway so we have these now let's
implement them
I get specification is something that
will just do here so override return
spec okay so binds obviously just calls
this and I'm Barnes just call this and I
don't really like to call Barnes here
because I think that's a bit weird or he
or other this should just be the opengl
card like this fine okay and also
because we might not even need to bind
them because if there are functions in
Europe in jail where you don't need to
use the whole state machine things and
then we don't firstly use them okay
that's that no no this is gonna work um
the last thing we actually need there at
least right now is if we want to be able
to get a color attachment out of this so
for now I just add a new entity here
called get color attachment renderer ID
so what this is going to do is just
return the color attachment so this is
just that we can bind it as a texture
because it the idea is we should just
give that to I'm GUI so this now becomes
no that's fine I think yep okay so
basically if I've done this right which
is very questionable but if I've done
this right then we just go over here we
we frame buff up in hazel then it over
here we can just say hazel raft
hazel frame buffer
then we do frame buffer okay so this is
how the whole spec system works so we do
hazel frame buffer specification if the
spec F and then you can call it
something actually good not FB spec but
we'll set the width to be well this
should be the size of our window which i
think is 1280 by 720 I don't even set
that window create just takes in I think
it just has some default parameters here
1280 720 so just for now you know we'll
talk about this more later but we'll set
it to 1280 by 720 what else we need I
think everything else is yeah samples
are set to 1 and we don't even using
that and for checkpoint sauce
and we're not using that so now we can
create the frame buffer so this is hazel
frame buffer create we pass in the spec
so that's kind of help that's what
that's what the card ends up looking
like unless you have like either
constructor here or you have like some
kind of other things that you can set up
usually it so you can obviously also set
it to like an initialize list like any
other struct or class really in C++ now
what we need to do is when we render
stuff we've always at the clear color
and do all that stuff let's do a quick
little render a prep we'll do a frame
buffer vines and then we'll do an on
bones and that's it so now we should be
rendering us into a frame buffer what we
should then do is decide to draw that on
you know I'm GUI so the way that we
currently were drawing this was we were
doing the checkerboard texture and
righty let's do something a bit
different
let's do and frame buffer yeah renderer
get a color attachment render IDs now
we're getting the color buffer from that
frame buffer which is where everything
should have been rented to and we're
ordering it let's not draw it as a
square cuz it's kind of bad let's do
like well 16:9 so if we do 320 by 180
and that'll be 69 and maybe the elbow
class that's just you know let's see if
this works because I'm very doubtful I
probably messed a lot of things up as
usual yep
okay so what are we looking at here we
have a frame okay so the frame F is not
complete do we have any other OpenGL
exceptions
okay levels width and height must be 1
or greater okay so something's weird
here invalid value generated there's a
clearly a fatal there's another thing
that I'm not very happy about in our era
so does Chloe happen happen from
somewhere here and it looks like some
looks like something may have been wrong
we are with ah what's this border no
this there might have been a place where
I accidentally set levels to 0 levels so
this should be 1 I believe that's
probably it but we should also you know
nah she's not happy about the framework
mean okay let's let's switch to the
hazel that part just to see if that's
the issue because obviously this code I
have actually tested and is working so
let's make sure that that's not the
reason and doesn't like it is what a
hater okay frame buffer incomplete what
did I do
you guys probably laughing at me um well
for one I mean I didn't bind the texture
because I think the reason I didn't
automatically bind it by the way is
because I was hoping I wouldn't meet you
because if yous like there are some I
don't know I didn't need to get caught
up on this but there are some like
OpenGL commands that have stopped taking
in this stupid thing here and started
taking in the actual ID and they're kind
of like named buffers and you know other
things I don't know if there's a named
texture
there's named frame buffer texture made
buffer data anyway I I'm kind of using a
mix of the older new API which is why
you know in this case I'm binding it
which is great but I think I wasn't
binding the color attachment and that
may have been the reason yeah it was a
reason okay so now you can see that what
have is we have the screen here that's
what we're rendering except now it's
like a little texture that we can see
anyway let's quickly go back to the
texture storage because that should work
as far as I'm going
they're all pro the real problem was me
not binding the texture yeah ok great so
there you go so now obviously what we
want to do is instead of making a tiny
like this four four one let's make it
1280 by 720 maybe because that is
slightly small so we'll do 1280 720 here
and that will be at least a little bit
bigger and obviously it'll just be the
size of no okay it's tiny why is that
why is the image so small
isn't that the image size 1280 by 720
hmm that's a bit weird
maybe that's yeah that is odd I don't
know why the image is so small oh well I
guess that's the way that it is
everything else looks good to me maybe
there's some other sizes controlling it
or maybe maybe I'm just a buffoon it's
probably the latter because I'm editing
the wrong the wrong code path because I
forgot I had to because that that by the
way something that I made for off camera
for another episode for the to make sure
that you could rent at the same last
time because that's the way it worked
you'll ever see we removed any kind of
by enabling docking we removed the
screen buffer being rounded as I had
mentioned and I wanted it to be rendered
so I just copied the code I made two
code paths I don't know why that was so
hard to explain um anyway yeah so there
we go here's our you know here's all
frayed before you can see that we're
rendering it and we're displaying it as
just an I'm good image so this is
basically like step one write the next
step and what we'll do next time is we
basically want to take this and actually
make a proper eye and glue a panel out
of it and then oh and obviously Kiva's
are still here they're act they're
actually active not in this window so if
you click here in the press levitate
doesn't work but in this window and
there's some things you can do obviously
to fix that but
ultimately my point is everything still
works and you should be able to you know
do everything like normal but minimizing
the windows also pauses it because
that's what we do I think if our main
window is minimized we yep if it's
minimize we stop updating everything and
obviously it minimized is the main
window not the window with the scene so
there's a few things you need to do if
you want to support this specifically
which is having multiple windows but if
it's all in here then obviously
everything works as expected and you'll
never be able to do anything about um so
yeah so next time what we want to do is
basically take the let's say to the full
cover view what we want to do next time
is take what we've done here and
actually make an IM Glee panel out of it
so that you know we have the viewport
panel basically and then we can we can
set the frame buffer size to be whatever
these size of the panel is so we take
the panel size from I'm GUI make that
our texture and frame buffer size and
then use that I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please hit the
like button don't forget that you can
help support the series on patreon.com
thoughts after the Cherno huge thank you
to everyone who does that is the reason
why we are here today so huge thank you
to everyone I really appreciate it
looking forward to next episode I'll
probably release it this week because
I'm having a lot of fun with this and I
obviously want to want to hurry up with
this so thank you all for watching I'll
see you next time goodbye
[Music]